Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
with the narration from Bkari Muslim on
the authority of Abbass regarding the
rebuilding of the Kaa by Ibraim and his
first son isam.
This story is mentioned by Allah
Subhanahu Waaala
in the first half of surah bak. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala recounts
the story of Ibraim and is rebuilding
the Ka the house of Allah.
Now we had arrived at the point in which
is dropped off as a an infant with his
mother Haj there in the valley of Mecca.
And Jabril
opened up the well of Zam for them. and
the travelers from Jon came traveling
by and started to settle there in the
valley of Mecca. And is
he grew up amongst them and it began to
become more and more populated and he
learned two very very critical and
important skills from them. The two main
skills that he learned. Do we remember
what they are?
Archery.
[Arabic recitation]
and archery.
Two of the most
unique traits of the Arab culture even
up until the time of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. They are blessed.
They are blessed
skills. and isam
continued to grow and grow until they
married one of their daughters to isam.
This is where we arrived at. We arrived
at the point in the story when is a
young man. He's newly married. He's got
his wife. He's married into the tribes
of Jum and he is in Mecca.
and
[Silence]
quiet.
And so time moves on
is married and his mother Haj passes
away as usual and is still living there
in Mecca in the valley and Ibraimis
now comes back to check on his
offspring. Now
I want you to really think about this.
Is
an infant last time Ibraim saw him
and now he is a young man who's married.
He left is there by Allah's command
and he came back after is had already
grown up and was married and his mother
has had passed away.
If this were to be viewed through the
lens of western culture today,
would he be viewed as this M's father
under those circumstances?
Huh? Say, "You didn't raise me. Where
were you when I was, you know, when I
needed you when I was a kid? You never
came to my baseball games. You never
came to my football games." Right? It
was just me and my mom against the
world.
I want you to notice something here. The
prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam doesn't
even address this issue because
fatherhood
is it earned
or is it by
its mere existence to be honored by
we are taught to honor fatherhood,
motherhood. Are we taught to honor our
fathers if they earn fatherhood?
Do they earn our honor? Or do we honor
our father simply because of the
position that they occupy as our father?
Meaning does Ibraimisam
have any less right as the father of is
to him than he does to his other son is
who he raised with him. Is he more of a
father to this one than that? No. He is
both of their fathers and he has the
right of fatherhood. This is something
very important, a point that many of us,
many of us who grow up in a western
culture fail to see. Fatherhood is not
earned.
Fatherhood is a state of being. When a
person is a father, we are commanded to
honor our fathers, to honor our mothers.
Not because they were nice and kind to
us. Not because they gave us and and and
taught us, but because of the fact that
they are our father, that they are our
mother and they are owed our obedience
and our respect regardless of how they
fulfill that position. This is an
important point. Ibraimisam
comes back. He finds that Hel has passed
away. Is out. He meets his wife.
He asks about is
she says, this is Ismael's wife. She
says he went out hunting. He's not here
right now. And then Ibraim asked her. He
didn't tell her who he was. She doesn't
know who this man is. She knows a man
came looking for my husband.
She didn't know who he is, that this is
her father-in-law.
He then asks her about their living
circumstances. How is life? How are your
circumstances?
This man is a stranger to her.
And so she says,
"And so when he asked how are you guys
living?
How how is your lifestyle?" She said,
"We are not in a good position.
We are not living comfortably. We are
living in a very difficult way." And she
started to complain to him.
She complained to him.
He listened.
And then he said,
She
[Silence]
Oh,
and sobb
listen to her complaints and her venting
and so forth. What is she complaining
about? She's not complaining about is
she's complaining about their
circumstances.
you know, oh, we don't have the in
today's words, we don't have the
furniture I and we don't have we
have only three bedrooms and we've got
so much we need five bedrooms and we're
renting still. We should be buying. We
should be owning our own house. That
kind of that kind of t talk. And so
Ibraimisam listened to this and he said
when he comes back tell him convey to
him my salam and tell him that I said to
change his stoop the stoop to his front
door and other wordings the threshold
which is the opening first part of the
entrance of the home. And then he left.
Isam
came back
and he felt something had occurred
in his absence. And so he asked her,
"Did anybody come by today?" She said,
"Yes, actually." An old man came by and
he was looking for you and I told him
that you were gone.
And he said, "Did he ask you anything?"
She said, "Yes." He asked me how we're
living. and I told him X, Y, and Z.
Probably the same thing that she was
nagging him about from before, right?
They've had this conversation before.
And I told him that we are living in
difficulty and we're living in this and
that.
And he said, "Did he tell you to say
anything to me?" She said, "Yes." He
said, "Now to her, this is a mystery. He
said to convey a salam to you." And he
said for me to tell you to change the
threshold or the entrance of your home.
Is said that is my father
and he has commanded me with that to
divorce you. Go to your parents and he
divorced her.
Let's take a stop here for a second.
Ibraimisam
heard how much
how much could he have heard?
A few minutes of conversation
but how much information did he get? He
got all the information that he needed.
This is a stranger
and the parable that he gave the analogy
he gave is very critical. Why? Because
when a person first and comes up to a
home, the first thing he is greeted by
is what? The threshold of the home,
how that is represented will set up your
expectations for the remainder of the
home.
And so when the wife, the caretaker, the
entrance, the threshold of Isma's home,
his homekeeper is representing him in
this negative way, this is all Iraim
needed to hear.
Now, are we to understand from this that
if a man's father or mother command him
to divorce his wife, is he obligated to
obey? Is this considered obedience to
one's parents? It's a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars.
The majority of the scholars they say it
is obligatory to obey the parents if
they have a religious
and if they if the mother or the
father and especially the father if he
has a religious
reason that he
has commanded his son to divorce his
wife then it would be obligatory. This
is what they say. What does this mean? A
religious reason mean the motivations
is the same motivations that Ibraim
here have here. And this happened in the
prophet's time. Abdullahbari
he had a wife that he really really
liked and his father Omar said divorce
her.
And so Iban Omar went and complained to
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
this is my wife and I love her and so on
and so forth but my father Omar has
commanded me to divorce her and the
prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam said
to Omar
obey your father and so Iban Omar
divorced her.
Now the scholars surmise from this this
narration is inmedi
that a person is to obey his parent in
this case.
Now the same thing happened in the time
of Imam Ahmed Ahmed bham.
A man came to him and said, "My father
has commanded me to divorce my wife."
And he explained to him the situation.
And I im Ahmed said to him,
"Do not obey him. Don't don't divorce
her." And so the man then said, "What
about the story of Ib, the one I just
mentioned to you?" He said, I im Ahmed
said to him
Omar, is your father Omar?
If your father is Omar, then yes,
divorce her. The meaning that the
scholars took from this ve very
intelligent, very precise understanding.
What Im Ahmed is saying and what is
understood here is Omar Kab's reasons
that he had to command his son to
divorce his woman are driven by his
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah driven
by his righteousness.
This man that came to Im Ahmed his
father was not driven by Islam to come
to this conclusion. He was driven by
what? personal personality,
right? I I never this girl. I don't
her. Right? But we know that he
forms his opinions based on what? Based
on his personality, not driven by
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah.
Therefore, if a person's father or
mother is driven by knowledge of the
Quran and Sunnah, your your father is a
scholar, your mother is knowledgeable,
your father is someone of someone
reputable of good standing in
knowledge and understanding of the Quran
and Sunnah, then yes, it becomes
obligatory to obey him in this instance.
However, if the driving force is mere
personality, then it is not obligatory
in this case. And we see this here with
who? With Ibraim. If your father is
Ibraim and he tells you divorce your
wife, what are you going to say? No,
this is this is Ibraim.
This is
and so is
immediately obeyed him
and rightfully so. We will continue this
very lengthy narration tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]